نعم هذا الهدوء تستغل ويستغلوا له سكان
الذين المناطق العسكريه هنا في جنوب
الخرطوم للخروج الى الشوارع لكنهم يواجهون
بعضهم من المشاكل المتعلقه بالسيوله
الماليه التي توفر لهم
القدره على الدفع لهذه المصادر الزمنيه
التي رفعت اسعارها تذكرتها الى اشياء غير
الى ارقام غير يعني في متناول لي في
متناول يد المواطنين بحكم انها ارتفعت
الاسعار كبيره هناك مشاكل اخرى معقده
بالنسبه
للجاليات المختلفه هذه الجاليات المختلفه
تواجه مشاكل معقده بالنسبه لهم نسيم
الجاليات السوريه والمصريه نوعا ما عدم
السودان لديه مقاري في المناطق المختلفه
فلذلك يمكن ان ينجحون اليهم اما اصحاب
الجاليات الاخرى
لا يتمتعون بهذه الظروف التي قد تكون
بالنسبه لهم جيده
فبالتالي هم يعانون من المشاكل يعانون من
بعض من الاشكاليات نحاول ان نتعرف على هذه
الاشكاليات مع
احدى المواطنين المصريين المصريين هنا
يعني من المشاكل التي تواجهونها في طريق
الخروج من جنوب الخرطوم الى مناطقكم او
الى مصر بالتحديد
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
حقيقي في صعوبه جامده جدا في خروجك من
العاصمه
لاي حدود مصريه او تمشي اي طريق
يعني ممكن تامن نفسك فيه
وللاسف الشديد
المواصلات مش متوفره خالص ولو متوفره
متوفره بمبالغ جامده جدا يعني النهارده
عشان تركب من هنا من الخرطوم لحدود اسوان
ب 500 الف جنيه مين قاعد معكم 500 الف
جنيه او هو واسرته مثلا معاه مبلغ زي ده
ازاي ما فيش اي وسيله تقول تبع دوله معينه
او حد يامننا هو عمل حظر للموضوع الضرب
وكده ما فيش ضرب ولا حاجه لكن الناس هتمشي
ازاي الطرق يعني شغاله لكن ما فيش فلوس ان
انت توصل
لحالفه عايز توصل عتبره بمبلغ وقدر الدنيا
مش مضبوطه خالص يعني كم عدد يعني انتم
كمصريين في المناطق التي جئت منها
لاعدادكم كبيرهمنها يعني عائلات قليله
كثيره جدا
اغلبيه المصريين اللي هنا كانوا قاعدين
مستقرين بقى لهم سنين طويله ومعاهم ولادهم
من مصر وفي اللي جايب حماته وجايب امه
معاه واستقر هنا واشتغل والدنيا كانت
ماشيه زي الفل يعني الدنيا كانت شغاله
كويس جدا جدا لاخر لحظه لا قبل الضرب
بساعه احنا في شغلنا في قلب العماير
شغالين وبننزل اسمنت ورمل وحديد وشغالينه
كويس في لحظه كل شيء تدمر في لحظه انت
مستقبلك مستقبل ولادك مش عارف تروح فين
ولا تيجي منين طيب بقى هي الخيارات التي
الان امامك وبعض السودانيين ينجحون الى
مناطق لديهم في اقارب ماذا عنكم انتم ما
الذي تفكرون فيهم ما هي الخيارات ما هي
مناشداتكم وطالبكم ايضا والله احنا بنناشد
طبعا الحكومه بتاعتنا يعني بنشد حكومتنا
المصريه يشوفوا حل السفاره بصراحه مش
شغاله خالص ما فيش اي حد بيعلنها في
السفاره يعني هضرب لك مثال بسيط فيه ولد
طالب مات اول امبارح من الطب هنا قعد 13
ساعه ساعه في السكن لما الجثه كانت هتعفن
مش عارفين نوصل لحد
وطلبنا السفير وطلبنا الدنيا كلها والهلال
الاحمر في الاخر دفناه هنا ما فيش اي حد
بيتعاون معنا في اي حاجه ما فيش على ارض
الواقع كله كلام على الفيس وتيجي تبص على
الهواء الواقع احنا جايين هنا حضرتك
دلوقتي بنوصل اسر يعني في ناس سابوا
ولادهم ومش موجودين فبنوصل الحريم
والاطفال قالوا هتلاقوا اتوبيسات توصلكم
لحد دنقله ما فيش اي حاجه على ارض الواقع
تعال قل لي فين الاتوبيس اللي بيمشي تعال
قل لي في ايه تبع السفاره هنا اللي ما
معهوش فلوس يعمل ايه يموت يعني هنا ولا
يعمل ايه الاكل والشرب الحياه بقت غاليه
جدا هنا بشراسه يعني في ناس استغلت الوضع
بطريقه غير عاديه يعني
شكرا جزيلا عثمان هذه
العينه وهذا الشخص
ربما يعكس معاناه الاجانب والمقيمين هنا
في السودان وبالتحديد في جنوب الخرطوم
لديه مشاكل معقده فيما يتعلق بحركته الى
خارج الخيارات بالنسبه لهم محدوده جدا هي
الدخول الى الى مناطق اكثر امانا لكن
بالنسبه للمصريين بالتحديد الان هم يفكرون
بالذهاب الى معبر اركين ومن ثم بعد ذلك
الى الى مدينه اسوان بجنوب مصر فلذلك هذه
المشاكل تزداد تعقيدا في ظل الظروف
الموجوده الندره فيما يتعلق بالوقود
الندره فيما يتعلق ايضا بالمواد الغذائيه
اذا الوضع بالنسبه للمقيمين وبالنسبه
للجاليات التي تسكن جنوب الخرطوم
معقده خيارات بالنسبه لهم الضيقه هناك
التقينا في هذه المنطقه بعدد من السوريين
والمصريين وكذلك
من البنغاليين في هذه المنطقه والهنود هم
ايضا يفكرون بالخروج ولكن
القصه انهم كيف يخرجون الى المناطق التي
تكون بالنسبه لهم اكثر ممنا امانا في ظل
انهم لا تتوفر لديهم سيوله ماليه تمكنهم
من الحركه هذا ان وجدوا ان المركبات التي
تقل من مناطقكم التي يقصدونها بالتحديد
نعم نعم يعني نشاهد خلفك عدد من الحافلات
يبدو ان هناك مشكله في الاسعار يعني
النقود ان وجدت فان المبالغ المطلوبه
كبيره وهذا ينطبق على السودانيين وغير
السودانيين يعني هذه مشكله اساسيه في
الانتقال من مكان لاخر ليس كذلك
المواطنين السودانيين الذين يقيمون في هذه
باعتباري ان لديهم اقارب في مناطق اخرى